alors on s'est rencontré sur les réseaux
sociaux il est venu vers moi il m'a
approché il m'a envoyé un message et
puis on a commencé à échanger voilà par
par message et puis très rapidement on
est venu à se rencontrer il m'a proposé
qu'on se rencontre au restaurant
d'accord euh ce qu'on a fait voilà j'ai
passé un bon moment globalement euh
c'était ouais très beau euh il s'est
voilà présenté comme un entrepreneur qui
travaillait dans l'or et les diamants
euh voilà on a passé un bon moment et
puis il m'a très rapidement suite à ce
rendez-vous expliqué qu'il voulait
quelque chose de sérieux avec moi qu'il
voulait s'engager dans une relation
exclusive moi aussi je recherchais du
sérieux à ce moment-là donc bah j'ai une
relation ce qu'on appelle une all
inclusive voilà exactement je connais
avec buffet à
volonté je connais je connais le bail
euh à partir de quand tu t'es dit qu'il
y avait un un loup quelque chose qui
était un peu chelou alors très
rapidement j'ai vu des signaux d'Alert
j'ai vu voilà j'ai découvert il y avit
beaucoup d'argent en liquide des faux
papiers des chèqus en blanc qui n'étaiit
pas à son nom comment tu as vu ça
comment tu as comment tu reconnais des
faux papiers par exemple bah il y avait
deux cartes d'identité avec sa photo
dessus mais avec des noms différents ah
ou
d'acc pas plus compliqué quand sur une
carte d'identité tu t'appelles Richard
Bouchard et sur l'autre Cyril Abdou un
problème tu vois oui donc j'ai demandé
des explications effectivement aux
éléments que j'ai trouvé et puis B
forcément il a toujours toujours réponse
à tout finalement c'était moi en fait
qui était enentort dans cette situation
puisque j'avais fouillé dans ses
affaires et j'avais tour comme ça
rappelle ça ça rappelle les trucs là sur
tu sais qu' là tu sais que tu regardes
là les trucs là tu sais les histoires là
genre des voisins tout ça là les trucs
là sur TFX
ouais ouais ouais ouais petit petit
secret
en on adore ça c'est vraiment les trucs
à chaque fois les mecs font mais tu es
fou pourquoi tu as volé dans tuasé dans
mes affaires Coral rien à non
mais c'est vrai c'était ça qu donc le
mec voilà exactement ça a duré combien
de temps cette affaire alors ça a duré
que 3 semaines ça a été assez rapide
puisque bon du coup voilà il y avait des
des signaux d'alerte euh mais voilà
après une dispute qui t'a demandé de
t'acheter de lu acheter un iphone ouais
euh ouais donc com comment comment il
est venu à te dire ça je sais plus voilà
il y avait une dispute et puis encore
une fois c'était de ma feu donc il
fallait que je me fasse pardonner pour
me faire pardonner il fallait que du
coup je m'investis dans laation basique
de base étage quoi VO que je lui prouve
mon engagement et pour lui prouver mon
engagement il fallait du coup que je
m'investisse dans l'achat d'un Ione tu
éta amouruse tu étais amoureuse tuis
alors c'était c'était de l'amour mais en
fait il avait beaucoup aussi de
d'emprise mais c'est dire tu tu t'es dit
ouais comme tu avais envie de te maquer
et quelqu'un tu t'es dit bon ça je vais
laisser sa chance j'étais aussi en
grande dépendance affective à ce
moment-là donc voilà ça a beaucoup joué
donc voilà le qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qu'il a essayer te te te voilà
t'extorquer voilà c'était quoi bah il a
voulu que je lui achète un iPhone euh
bon du coup je l'ai pas fait voilà je
expliqué que là actuellement j'avais pas
forcément l'argent pour mettre des de
l'argent dans un iPhone il m'a expliqué
que du coup je n'avais qu'à faire un
emprunt pour l'acheter sur un an quoi ah
ouais quand même je je l'ai pas fait non
plus et puis en fait au même moment
cétait cofid le gars ou quoi ouais et
donc donc au même moment en fait je
j'avais une carte bancaire que je
retrouvais plus ouis je la trouvais plus
chez moi enfin c'était bizarre et puis
je viens voilà checker ce compte que je
sur lequel je ne vais jamais je vois
qu'il y a des prélèvements qui ont été
faits qui ont été fait dans des
commerces qui sont aux alentours de où
il habit et il y a un prélèvement aussi
sur une société à son nom donc je fais
facilement la la relation entre les
événements et je comprends que c'est un
ESCR alors tu te rends vite compte qu'en
fait tu es pas la seule victime oui
effectivement parce que du coup je
commence un petit peu par en parler sur
mes réseaux sociaux ouais et puis je
fais notamment un TikTok et je me rends
compte que ce TikTok fait beaucoup de
vues et que dans les commentaires il y a
des centaines de victimes en fait qui
ont été éit euh escroqué par cette même
personne des centaines et estce et
est-ce que à ce moment-là à ce moment-là
de la relation comme tu t'es attaché et
il y avait une certaine passion et une
dépendance affective est-ce que tu as
quand même réussi à ressentir le
sentiment de jalousie par rapport aux
autres femme ou est-ce que tu t'es
détaché directement alors euh quand
j'étais dans la relation bien sûr qu'il
y avait de la jalousie même si tu savais
que c'était un escroc tu as quand même
fes pour comprendre l'emprise que tu as
eu non non quand j'étais dans la
relation et quand je ne savais pas
encore cétait que c'était un C mais
après quand j'ai vu qu'il m'avait trompé
sur l'intégralité de la relation
non et n'as pas souffert
psychologiquement en tout cas alors si
il y a eu un petit choc post-traumatique
je dirais
euh mais j'ai pas souffert en fait de la
peine de que la relation se termine mais
voilà de de la du contexte en fait dans
lequel ça s'est passé et du coup ça
m'aon voilà ça m' il a été attrapé lui
par la J ou alors il a été actuellement
il est incarcéré actuellement je crois
qu'il é incarcéré donc ce qui veut dire
que la personne est donc incarcéré donc
elle est dans un endroit où elle ne peut
pas sortir forcément j'ai eu les copains
de la
drpce les copaines je les connais de la
drpce qui continu un petit peu disons
c'est l'ARSIN au sein de l'établissement
de pénitentière non et donc
conter et du coup ouais là actuellement
il est il est incarcéré mais alors il a
pas été mis sous écrou par rapport aux
arnaques mais par rapport à une autre
affaire avec une de ses ex compagnes du
coup euh pour qui il y a eu du Revenge
porne et euh
du tu as perdu combien toi au total
alors moi euh il a volé ma carte et il
ne pouvait faire que des paiements sans
contact donc voilà c'était un mouton qui
s'est levé à du 200 300 € il a pas pu
aller très loin euh voilà je suis après
voilà l'iPhone tu lui as jamais
donnéureement voilà juste tu t'es rendu
compte qu'il avait arnaqué des des
centaines de G parce que je vois les les
et qu'est-ce qu'ell tont dit dit les
autres victimes il a fait il en a fait
quoi ben les autres victimes elles me
racontent voilà des situations qui sont
un peu comme la mienne il y en a qui
sont allés malheureusement un petit peu
plus loin elles sont allé il y a eu plus
de manipulation que que que la mienne
euh il y a eu des des crédits à la
consommation qui ont été fait il y a
voilà des jeunes filles qui lui ont qui
leur ont donné leur carte de crédit
voilà il étaient totalement libre avec
euh il y a eu de l'argent qui a été
prêté euh voilà ce type de eu des
plaintes des plaintes oui oui il y a des
des cinquantaines de plaines voilà moi
aussi j'ai porté plaines mais c'est
difficile à prouver c'est c'est de
l'abus de confiance moi c'est difficile
à prouver qu'il m'a volé ma carte en
fait finalement comment est-ceir dire
c'est
toiou lui a donné est-ce que c'était
c'était quand cette affaire céit il y a
un an il y a un an et depuis tuas tu en
as tu en as pris le son alors depuis moi
je me protège beaucoup plus par rapport
au rencontres auquell je
fais on a le droit de demander sur quel
site c'était ou pas oui c je sais pas
pour la loi
moi c'était un réseau social c'était pas
un c'était sur insta cétait sur
instacord
euh et voilà moi je fais beaucoup plus
attention et je sais maintenant que en
fait j'ai toujours senti finalement que
il y avait quelque chose qui clochait
ouais tu l'as jamais senti ce gars oui
j'ai jamais senti
mais la dépendance et la manipulation
était plus forte ouais ça puis bon tu
t'es dit tu t'es dit moment tu t'es dit
voilà tu t'es tu t'es fourvoyé tu t' je
commence une histoire tout ça on va
laisser sa chance au produit voilà je
voulais trouver l'amour quoi je voulais
croire je sais dis j'attends l'amour de
mes rêves et donc ouais donc aujourd'hui
tu maintenant voilà je fais je fais conf
ça à mon instinct quand je sens pas
quelque chose j'y vais pas c'est vrai ah
ouais et là tu en es où là alors euh bah
là maintenant voilà je vis ma
vie voilà donc tu es tranquille voilà tu
es pas tu es pas tu es pas la recherche
voilà non tu es pas choqué outre mesure
bah je l'ai été pendant un petit moment
voilà mais ça va mieux maintenant j'ai
j'ai tourné la comment comment tu as su
qu'il était incarcéré parce que j'aita
euh des collègues comment tu as qu'
était un carcéé parce qu'en fait du coup
grâce à mon mon TikTok j'étais en
relation avec plusieurs victimes alors
tik bien sûr oui et donc désolé et donc
et j'ai mon du coup euh je donc j'étais
en relation avec une victime notamment
qui a porté plainte et euh bah ça
procédure à à a fonctionné puisque voilà
je j'ai plus allé à sur audience et j'ai
ah donc c'est c'est en cours il y a pas
tout qui a été rejeté non plus enfin
c'est en cours il y a une ente quand
même il est pas il est pas incarcéré
làors si si là il est actu
depc c'est pour une autre affaire oui il
faisait ça depuis vous avez après
remonté la la pelote il c'est quelqu'un
qui a fait ça pendant des années avant
ou pas oui tu l'as tout fait ça toute sa
vie il y a des gens que j'ai rencontré
ça faisait pe-être 7 ans il avaient
comment comment il arrivait à manipuler
comme ça c'est quoi c'est quoi son après
les copains du
spipe au téléphone non c'est comment il
Arve à comment il arrive parce que vous
n'avez pas l'air naïve comme ça donc
comment il est arrivé à vous bah en
amour tu sais oui oui
c'est de la manipulation et c'est ce
qu'on appelle le Love bombing c'est ce
qu'explique les les les psychiatres
notamment un psychiatre américain qui a
fait une éud là-dessus et qui explique
qu'en fait c'est le fait de donner
beaucoup tout de suite aller très
rapidement dans la relation euh
s'investi beaucoup et créer une forme de
dépendance en fait quand on rentre dans
cette spirale finalement c'est très dur
en fait d'avoir d'être clairvoyant en
fait sur ce qui se passe tu te projette
directement en même temps avec la
personne parce que c'est agréable sur le
coup et après tu te rends compte que
c'était juste sur le coup voilà ex ça
Guillaume après on va non mais là où ils
sont très forts c'est qu'ils savent quoi
faire pour pas se faire attraper c'estàd
que ils demandent à leur compagne de
souscrire à des prêts il leur demande de
leur acheter des choses et après ils
disent bah moi c'est ma copine qui m'
acheté ça donc j'ai rien et l'arnaqueur
de tinder qui a arnaqué plusieurs
millions d'euros il a rien eu du tout
oui il estal vrai il été condamné pour
autre
chose et c'est là où qu' N a pas de
preuve il faudrait que la justice
reconnaisse davantage la manipulation
qui se voit par message par SMS et et
qui puisse les condamner plus rapidement
parce que la manipulation évidenteas des
c'est en tout cas on on a rigolé un peu
par pas trop choé que ça va
aujourd'ui
devfér la
semaine